pour beaucoup l'hypersexualisation c'est
ça l'invasion du truck et du boutis
tchèque l'an défi de dancehall qu'ils
n'ont de la 3 et le petit écran
mais le phénomène est souvent plus
subtil plus à voir si dans la pub
il est quelquefois explicite ils
véhiculent aussi des messages dissimulé
alimentant des stéréotypes en tous
genres sur l'homme comme sur la femme
ces messages qui passent parfois
inaperçus altère les perceptions format
aps des jeunes esprits et modifient
durablement la sexualité leur rapport à
l'autre ils sont aussi à l'origine de
troubles divers allant de l'anorexie aux
troubles sexuels sous couvert d'humour
et de divertissement
l'hypersexualisation est désormais
partout
occupant toujours un peu plus de place
dans notre société
[Musique]